welcome back guys Matt here code second
Trails I wanted to talk a little bit
about shaders and uh how they're often
done in game engines and programs and uh
just some things I've learned recently
that have kind of changed my uh mindset
a bit about how I'm going to approach
shaders featuring I'm talking about
shaders for games game edges you know
things that make the graphics look fancy
and feel lights and shadows mess up that
kind of thing yeah let me show you what
I've learned first a few observations if
you learn from like learn opengl and
stuff they teach you how to make a
Shader and if you go off of what most
people are kind of doing and show you
online you end up with the system uh
where basically you have this Shader
class handles making a Shader and you
kind of make some functions to make sure
it says stuff properly on your Shader so
you pass in the source and create your
Shader you've got to have your Source
somewhere and you got to decide what
Shader you're using for me I have these
internal shaders that kind of work for
very specific scenarios and mainly the
one I use when I'm doing most stuff
that's just normal rendering we'll say I
have this thing I call Uber Shader and
the more I add to it the more complex it
gets don't worry I'm getting to a point
and essentially why this isn't going to
work in the future
essentially as I add more stuff I have
to add more uniforms
set more stuff now as as I add more
uniforms I end up with scenarios like
well what if it doesn't have this and it
does have that and just a lot of if else
type stuff which gets very confusing
after a while like what if it has no
point lights when it has no directional
light what if it has tint but not
something else but if it has a specular
texture so I have these integers for has
a specular texture and then then it's
making a texture and I probably just
like convoluted and confusing and kind
of hard to reason about and when you try
to add another thing and you gotta kind
of it's like a Cascade of effects of
things you got to change in your Shader
to support it or you could just make a
whole new Shader and have just like a
million different little shaders for
different things you support or
different scenarios going on and it just
becomes kind of like mind-bogglingly
large and it's just really hard to keep
keep working with so I started realizing
something and I realized this before but
I just didn't understand it so I'm gonna
open Unreal Engine and just show you a
thing launching unreal and eating ice
cream I've been moving stuff all day so
I'm like super hot that's why I had to
cut my hair too it's just too hot not
that you guys wanted or need to know any
of that but subscribe if you look at
this what it's doing here is it says as
it's opening this project editor for
some little project I was working on it
says compiling shaders down here and you
see this a lot when you're working
you'll see that it's compiling shaders
and everything's lagging things don't
look right what does it mean by
compiling shaders it doesn't just have
shaders ready for like PBR and different
lighting scenarios and stuff so this got
me thinking like what are they doing and
here's what they're doing well you can
go look at the code and see it's kind of
hard to find an unreal code because the
code base is so huge but essentially
what they're doing is they're figuring
out what you need and they're actually
making the shaders they don't have a
giant Shader with a bunch of if else
they it literally just builds what
you're actually using and I'll show show
you a good example of this from the
blender source code because they do a
similar thing so if we just Google
search for blender source code if you go
to source
and then blender but let's look a little
deeper there's some basic Shader stuff
they got a path pass through shaders so
they do have some shaders that are
really straightforward that you need
like a passive Shader because it
literally just wants the depth so you
don't need to actually do anything okay
so it takes a little digging around to
find but I think it's actually under GPU
opengl there's all the opengl render
code okay if we're going to shaders here
see a bunch of Shader stuff you can
click on anything kind of see what they
do this just has a main and let's look
at common there's a lot of these there's
some math stuff I don't even know if
there's a main in this one
nope there's no main in this one it's
just a bunch of functions so they end up
including what they need as they build
the shaders now here's where things get
really cool let me see if I can find
this okay let's look at these GL
shader.ct files so what you'll see here
is they have well they have a GL Shader
file kind of like I did in my engine
except theirs and it actually controls a
little bit more I just make the Shader
program and ignore all the other stuff
once it's created I think it gets
deleted but they actually hold on to
those because they probably reuse them
in a smart way you'll see here things
like
functions like this these two strings
and you'll see like some cases and what
it does they're returning const carriers
which are essentially strings and you
see things like this here too
now what these are doing is these are to
build shaders so they have all these
functions to build based on what you're
doing on blender so they have these all
worked out to where when you're working
with things like the node editor now I
don't know if this is 100 accurate but
it's just for a case of example so I got
this little Starship here I got it from
open game art or something I forget but
if we go to shading let's just open a
new one of these and turn it to Shader
editor and if you go to your material
all right so you got to click use nodes
and it brings it up over here in your
little compositor and your uh Shader
editor and you get this sort of thing
this principle principle bsdf So based
on how you like edit these nodes it
builds you the proper Shader for these
different materials and generally you
get like a Shader per material based on
how it's set up and it's using Code like
this to actually build the Shader on the
Fly and then it just didn't close what
engine do obviously this gets very
complicated it's over a thousand lines
of code it's most this one in particular
is just mostly switch statements but you
can see how they build their shaders
they bring in all their uniforms and
variables as needed and build it up like
that and it's like it's just a
conglomeration of oh there's not a whole
lot of set shaders there's a few for a
very specific things but otherwise
they're like building them on the fly so
that way you're getting exactly what
you're needing and you don't have to do
this Uber Shader thing with a bunch of
switch statements in it so that's what
I've learned recently about how shaders
are often done in most engines and 3D
editors and stuff but for specific games
it is different sometimes they have
specific shaders for games and like
Minecraft for example a lot of people
make shaders for Minecraft to do
specific things they just uh they bring
in new ones because Minecraft has
specific built-in ones all right so I'm
looking at it's just a little demo scene
a world in unreal you can see it's
preparing shaders down here at the
bottom right so that's one of the things
it's doing is it's it's probably
scanning through all the materials all
the models all the light and stuff and
just building the proper shaders for all
your features
shadows and everything
so it's going through code probably
somewhat like this blender source code
but unreal just making it forsaken
example because they probably do
somewhat of a similar thing I'm sure
their code's actually different but the
concept probably about the same and of
course this is using hlsl well that
blender one oh we were looking at glsl
but it all kind of means the same thing
so in the meantime they give you like
some some basic demo uh shaders that are
good enough to display things that's why
they have this preview but they're not
like the optimized ones that get built
based on exactly what you're doing and
how you have all your light stuff set
and uh that I thought I just thought
that was really interesting and I don't
know if people really know that when
they start out but it's something that's
kind of important to realize otherwise
you'll just kind of be stuck in the
world of trying to make your own custom
shaders and if you're making an engine
or you want to sport a bunch of
different things or 3D editor or you
want to support node editing and stuff
like that you essentially need to come
up with some kind of Shader Builder
system and maybe there are some open
source projects that handle a lot of
this for you already I'm not sure
obviously there's the blender source
code and stuff like that but it would
take a lot of work to get that worked
into your own engine so that is
something that really made me kind of
step back and analyze how I was doing
shaders in my engine and uh consider
maybe I shouldn't be making this Uber
Shader because well it's probably better
to make a Shader Builder kind of like
blender and unreal and unity of pretty
much all the engines will do it's
probably better to do something like
that in the long run a bunch of if else
it's in a massive Shader depending on
what's being used because ultimately you
don't want these in here if they're not
being used and that's kind of where the
problem comes in
because you're just going to have
massive a massive Shader with a bunch of
unused stuff now will that be better
than creating a bunch of custom shaders
I don't know probably not because with
all the if else is going to be slow and
you don't want that in your graphics
pipeline you want it to just be
optimized which those Shader Builders
will do but and just as a last thing you
know if you're making an engine for a
very specific game and you only want to
support very specific lighting stuff and
you don't want to give a ton of options
in a note editor then you probably don't
need a Shader Builder you probably just
want your custom Shader for exactly what
you want to do because you can still
optimize it based on your game so that's
probably the route I'm gonna go but uh
yeah that was something that just uh I
really think people should be aware of
because you don't really get taught that
or at least I didn't when I started
learning about shaders but I think
that's super important to realize and
it'll probably make a big difference for
a lot of people going forward so let me
know hit the like button if you enjoyed
the video and uh I'll be around might
take a few days off here because I'm
probably going to try to get a lot of my
moving done but uh we'll see all right
peace out guys
foreign